foreign
[Music]
spoilers show I'm your host Paul and
this video we're breaking down all the
big updates from Star Wars celebration
it's been a massive massive week for
trailers I was going to be spending some
time with my family today but YouTube
comes first and thus I've became a worse
father than Darth Vader however there's
lots of things to talk about so our
mission through this video is to boldly
go where no one has gone before and talk
about everything that you need to know
from the event now it opened with a
Sizzle reel of all the Star Wars content
that's coming the next couple of years
Kathleen Kennedy then arrived on stage
her eyes glowing red like those YouTube
thumbnails and she basically started to
go through everything that was coming up
now the first panel that they dropped
was for Andor and the cast joined Tony
Gilroy on stage to talk about the new
season this is actually gonna finish
filming in August and as we know it's
going to lead directly into Rogue one
and because of this they kind of have a
rough idea when the release date is
going to be and they said on stage at
its likely summer 2024 Tony Gilroy
discussed a lot of things that were
going on in the season and we also ended
with Andy Circus chanting one way out so
yeah lots of things teasing towards what
could be coming down the line I'd love
to see Andy Circus back and though the
character couldn't swim he might not be
in too deep and be able to get out of
this situation now next up was the
Acolyte and this came with a brand new
logo for the show according to
discussing film Kathleen Kennedy said
she was blown away by the four finished
episodes of the show and that she
absolutely loved it we're also going to
have a Wookie Jedi in it and though it
might not be gungy we do have a feeling
that it could be him Lee jong-jae will
also Star as a Jedi master in the show
and the series is going to take a heavy
focus on martial arts lucky people at
the panel got to see the trailer really
and they said it featured lots of
lightsaber twirling you know those fancy
Twirls lots of martial arts and
basically lots of things that make her
look amazing the next it was the
Mandalorian where they sort of touched
upon what's come before and those
upcoming two episodes of season three
seven minutes of episode 7 were also
shown on stage and the cast also stepped
up and talked now from here we went to
John Watts's Skeleton Crew which
apparently is now in post-production
following a group of kids they go on an
adventure throughout the Galaxy and this
will be led by Jude Law attendees there
got shown an exclusive trailer and there
were also images posted that showed the
crew together next up was Ahsoka and if
you've been paying attention to YouTube
then you'll see the full trailers drop
something's coming
[Music]
something dark
is it I absolutely loved it it's got so
many cool Easter eggs in it you know
just seeing those Rebel characters
brought to life really blew me away and
I can't wait to see it this actually
releases in August knowing my luck it'll
probably be on my birthday on the 8th uh
so make sure you get your card ready for
that and yeah lots of things to unpack
when we break down that trailer probably
at some point later in the week because
I want a weekend off please guys just
let me have some time off now we do know
a lot about the cast and Natasha Lee
buddyzo will be playing Sabine Wren Mary
Elizabeth Winstead will also Star as
Hera and we're gonna get Genevieve
O'Reilly who'll be returning as mon
Mothman thrawn will be featuring two and
though I don't think we've got any
casting announcements when it came to
him we did see the back of his head
which it's the back of his head let's go
wild
they are also recreating the finale
rebels in live action as well and
everything is really coming together in
the season to build off the back of that
how popular it is is going to depend
massively on how big the fan base is for
Rebels but I love it and thus I loved
seeing this trailer I'm sure there's
lots of newbies out there who have no
idea who these characters are so if
that's you then let me know your
thoughts below so yeah lots of things to
talk about a nerdy sub on Twitter even
pointed out that we might see Ezra in
the trailer no one's really talking
about it but yeah I think it's worth
putting out an absolutely Blown Away by
how good this trailer looks anyway from
here Kathleen Kennedy appeared on stage
again
and she said that it was time to
announce the future of Star Wars films
fingers crossed these actually get made
I might be wasting your time going over
them but you know it is important to
talk about so yeah let's let's get into
it now the first big announcement it's
gonna get a lot of Goodwill with fans I
think and that is that Dave filoni will
be directing a film set after the events
of the mandobus likely picking up with
the Mandalorian characters I think that
is kind of the natural progression now
because that season three has been a bit
rough personally I think it would have
worked great as just one big binge or
potentially put into a film so we didn't
have those weird cameos that keep
popping up to fill up the season anyway
James Mangold will also be directing a
Star Wars film too and this will be
about the first Jedi described as a
Biblical epic this is really really
interesting to me my mangold's an
incredible director in my opinion and
seeking work on Star Wars will be
something really breathtaking the fact
is about the first Jedi as well can
really flesh out that backstory that we
haven't really seen in I've action
before and I think they've got the right
guy for the job here to deliver a home
run next is the big announcement that
you've probably seen blowing up on
Twitter so follow me at heavy spoilers
and that is shamina Bay Chennai will be
directing a Star Wars film set with a
new Jedi Order set 15 years after the
sequel Trilogy it's gonna see Daisy
Ridley returning his race Star Wars
sorry race Skywalker personally I'm
hoping that John byega returns as well
as I think Finn was just picked up and
dropped after the force awakens the guy
was clearly teased as being a Jedi and
with Rey rebuilding the Jedi Order I
think it makes sense to at least bring
him in as one so yeah those are the main
announcements whether these movies
actually get made you know you really
don't know when it comes to lucasfilm
but fingers crossed they do because they
all sound really interesting I'm
guessing that they're just kind of in
the planning stages at the moment
uh my my bet on my safe bet would be
that the days you really want at least
gets made and then they kind of build
off that but yeah it's gonna go down a
bit of a bit of a storm I think with
people's reactions on Reddit Ray was
obviously a very mixed character
um so yeah let me know below if you're
interested in seeing this movie or if
you're not I think in general when Star
Wars things are announced you know
people often do go in with Goodwill and
even if they've hated things in the past
they're like well you know maybe this
could turn it around generally the
reaction that I tend to see from fans is
that they're willing to give everything
a chance if they've been invested in the
universe before and therefore I think
that people are genuinely positive
towards this however you know we will
end up seeing the fact that Dave filoni
is getting a movie as well I think
that's really important as it's
something that us fans have been crying
out for years and years and years now
guy clearly understands Star Wars to me
he's the most trusted person you know
but the franchise in his hands and I
think he'll do really well with it and
yeah I am glad to see that announcement
at least coming through so yeah lots of
things to talk about there we kind of
rushed through it um obviously we
weren't in attendance at the panel there
there are people that were so if you
were there and you're watching this
video back thinking you got that wrong
or he didn't talk about this enough then
yeah the comment section guess what it
was designed specifically for you to be
able to leave your thoughts I'll let you
go ahead and do it um if you appreciate
me taking some time away from my family
for this and uh I'd also appreciate the
thumbs up and make sure you subscribe
for Star Wars breakdowns almost every
week we are going to be doing the
Mandalorian episode seven on Wednesday
so keep an eye out for that if you want
something else to watch then there's a
video on screen right now thank you for
bearing with me I've been Paul I hope
you enjoy the rest of Easter you take
ASL peace yeah those Easter eggs in you
could say hey
[Music]